-Our first guest tonight
is a Grammy-nominated comedian
who is hosting
"Saturday Night Live" this week,
right here on NBC,
with musical guest Foo Fighters.
Please welcome back
to the show Nate Bargatze.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, man.
-What's up, man?
-I'm so --
-Thank you.
-Hey, bear!
-Hey, bear. Hello, folks.
-I'm so happy you're here.
I'm so happy the reason
you're in New York --
you're hosting "SNL."
-Yes.
-This is such a blast.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's -- Yeah, it's insane, dude.
It was like -- It's almost --
When they asked, you're like,
"I don't know if I'm famous
enough to do that."
Like, you want to -- Almost,
I want to tell them that.
They're like,
"We're going to get you."
I was like,
"Guys, I appreciate it,
but there's some other people
I think y'all should go after."
You're like,
"Your show has a legacy.
You don't want to mess
around with that."
-You're "SNL, dude."
I go, "Look, thanks for
the offer, but, you know...
I'm doing you a favor."
-You've played -- Obviously,
you've played
New York City a ton.
You've played big rooms
in New York City a ton.
How are the nerves
on Tuesday here?
-So far, it's good.
This was the first day --
I mean, you know what?
They called me Sunday
about, like, a sketch idea.
And I was like, "Oh, man,
it's, like, happening."
Like, it was Sunday.
-Yeah.
-And then, Monday, you come in,
and, I mean, you really --
I'm really waiting
for them to be like,
"We're not going to air this."
Like, they're -- Like,
I'm just some trial show
that they're like,
"We just wanted to make sure
the cameras worked."
Someone -- Like,
Vin Diesel's backstage.
And I'm like, "Is he on?"
And you're like,
"What's he doing?"
You're like,
"Don't worry about him."
-He just doesn't like
doing dress anymore.
And you're like,
"These are a lot of
Vin Diesel-type sketches."
-I don't know if I
can sell these, dude.
-I will say, when I was there
on the writing staff,
the greatest feeling was
when a stand-up would show up
because you knew they would
handle their own monologue.
Do you --
Is that safe to assume
that you were going to
write your own monologue?
-Yeah, yeah. That's the only
thing I can do that's good.
Like, I ran it last night.
It was great
because I got to, like --
You know,
I've been on the road,
so it's like you're doing
an hour, and then --
So, last night, I came in,
and last night
I ran around and did spots
and, you know, trying to
figure out --
The one idea I thought I was
going to do --
it's kind of changed.
And so then you're like --
You're just kind of trying to
figure out the --
you know, rough eight minutes
or so that we're going to work.
-When you
run around New York City,
so you're going to different
clubs, you're doing spots.
Do you let them know, "Hey,
I'm going to be doing this
on Saturday at 'SNL.'"
Do you give them that preface?
-Yeah, yeah.
-The host said -- I mean, like,
if I go up and go,
"This will be on 'SNL.'"
And then they go...
I would, just go,
"Just so you know,
this is on 'Saturday Night Live'
this Saturday."
It's -- You do --
I mean, I remember
following a lot of comics
that would come in
and run in for a spot,
and so it's very cool.
You do want the audience
to know -- I would do it
with late-night sets,
when you'd run those to be like,
"Just tell them
this is what I'm doing."
So the audience understands
you're doing 5 minutes
or 8 minutes, whatever it is.
It's very tight.
It's just a little
different feeling.
But you have to get back
into the New York rhythm.
Like, the New York rhythm --
Because when I lived here,
it's very --
You know, it's, like, quick.
It's like you've got to be
just on top of them.
And, you know, instead of, like,
when you do a long show,
it's, like, a little more.
And so, I mean, I had to,
like -- I did five sets,
and it took me a good three
just to get back into New York.
One of them did not go good.
-Yeah.
-It's so funny because people
will say to me sometimes,
"Oh, my God,
I can't even imagine
what it's like to go onstage
and do an hour."
And you're like, "Weirdly,
it's easier than doing five."
-Yes.
-Because an hour,
they get to know you.
You know,
realize they're not seeing
the best five minutes first.
But when you've got to do five,
they're like, "Wait.
This is the five?"
-Yeah, this is it.
They go, "You're doing
that this Saturday?"
I get a couple of that.
They're going, "You're doing
this on -- Alright."
-And they're like,
"Honey, I think we can
wake up early on Sunday,
because we're going to get
a good night's sleep."
-People will just tune in
for the sketches.
They're like,
"We'll watch the sketch."
It's like,
that's the worst I'm at.
They're like, "But we've seen
this other, so..."
-Now, a lot of people might
think you're flying high
because you're hosting "SNL,"
but you had an allergic reaction
in Wichita.
Was this before a show?
-This was an hour
before the show.
-Okay.
-I tried to go running,
tried to do the right thing
for my dumb body.
That's what's infuriating,
because you go,
"I'm doing what
I'm supposed to do, man,"
and then your body falls --
Like, I don't --
I don't remember ever
being allergic to anything.
And I guess you just get
old and weak
and you can't handle air and...
-So, this is --
You posted a photo of yourself.
You look pretty, uh, yeah.
Was it mid-run that you realized
it was happening or...
-We did --
We were having to do two laps.
So, it was mid-run, we go back.
-Those are those mile laps?
-Yeah. Yeah, mile.
We do two laps around the bus.
And...
-It's a big bus.
-It's a big bus, everybody.
So, I go back.
My hands start itching.
My feet are itching.
And it's Wichita, which has
some of the most allergies.
Like, you know, and those people
are some strong people
because they're breathing in
that stuff.
And it was, like, ragweed.
I guess it just hit me wrong.
So that goes up -- I mean,
we're an hour before the show,
and it's like this.
I was like, "This is not good."
And, so, then my buddy is like,
"You should take Benadryl."
But I was like, "That's going
to make me fall asleep.
You know,
I don't want to take it."
We got an EMT came down,
and he was a super-nice guy,
bless his heart.
But it was his first day.
-Yeah.
-And so he was not --
He doesn't have
the stuff for this.
-Yeah.
-And, so, he just came in --
-By the way,
that's a different person.
-It's a different person.
And, so, he came in
and was like, "I don't know."
You know...
And then he didn't know --
Like, you know,
if you work at --
you don't know who everybody is.
-Sure.
-And, so, he comes down there
and then he goes,
"So, your name is
Travis Mathew,"
because I have this shirt on.
It's just the brand.
And I just said, "Yeah."
I just went with it
because it's --
You know, am I going to go
into a whole thing about it?
You know, I was like, "Just
write, yeah, Travis Mathew."
You know?
Like, "I'm Ralph Lauren. I am.
My friends call me Polo."
So, I'll just do
whatever that guy said.
-That's weirdly -- The most
insulting thing is he thought
you were a guy who would just
have your own name.
-Yeah. That into my shirt to --
We ended up getting --
Another doctor came, Dr. Sean.
Goes-by-first-name-only
doctor, so that's --
-Those are the guys you get
at venues right before a show.
-Yeah.
-They're, like,
first-name doctors.
-Those, you got to be like,
"Where's the bottle
for these pills?"
And there's just no bottle,
because it's all --
He goes, "I got a few things
down here."
-Yeah, Dr. Sean doesn't
like follow-up questions.
-Yeah, he doesn't.
He goes, "Dr. Sean."
I go, "Can I see your ID?
He goes, "I left it in the car."
But he was very nice, too.
And, like, he gave --
And I ended up
having to take Benadryl.
Then I fall asleep.
And, so, then I had to
give my assistant --
I was like, "You got
to wake me up, dude,
like, if I fall asleep."
And I fell asleep hard
because of Benadryl.
And then I did -- And I got up.
I mean, I was --
Within eight minutes
of being the most asleep,
I was just in front
of 6,000 people.
-And were you cognizant
of that whole act of like,
"I'm out of it," or did you --
once you
got in front of the audience,
did it kind of lock in,
like muscle memory?
-Yeah, it went in.
You know what?
The show was great.
I almost think it was
a lot more freeing.
Like, I was all --
You know, I'm on Benadryl.
I'm like -- I'm up there like,
"We're having a pretty good time
tonight, folks."
Like, I go, "Nice and easy,"
you know?
My wife told me --
Because I was telling her this,
and she said --
Because we're worried
about being nervous
on "Saturday Night Live."
And she was like,
"Well, if you can do this,
you might be all right."
Like, just to wake up and
then go talk to 6,000 people.
But they were awesome.
-I will tell you, after --
If between dress and air,
you'll know dress
didn't go well if Lorne goes,
"Maybe some Benadryl?
Do you want it?"
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
A whole bottle.
-He goes,
"I've heard Benadryl helps."
-Dr. Sean's there.
I go, "How'd you find him?"
-Oh, yeah.
Oh, trust me, Lorne's got
a bunch of Dr. Seans.
You mentioned your wife.
I've always talked about
I'm so such a fan
of the material you do
about her onstage.
She does not seem to be someone
who puts you on a pedestal,
based on the material
you do about it.
Is she excited, though,
about Saturday?
-Very excited.
This one's very exciting.
I mean, we've been together
before I ever started comedy,
so it's -- You know, I think
that's a big reason for that.
And -- But she's very excited
about "Saturday Night Live."
This is definitely something.
It really is crazy.
It's -- I mean,
I can't even des--
Like, you're just really shocked
that I'm even here.
And so everybody has been --
Everybody is super-excited.
She's a big fan
of the Foo Fighters, as I am --
-Yes. That's an exciting thing,
as well.
-Yeah. Yeah.
That was probably her most
excitement, was that.
Like, I feel like
that's what impressed her.
-Yeah.
-I didn't even choose.
It's like I went in and go,
"I'd like the Foo Fighters."
This is my first time hosting.
And the Foo Fighters, please.
-She heard that.
She was like,
"Oh, that's how they can get
away with you hosting."
-Yeah, exactly.
-"They got the Foo Fighters."
-Oh, yeah. It's going to be
all Dave Grohl in every sketch.
I'm just kind of on the show.
Yeah, so, very excited.
I get a lot of sketch ideas.
Do you get --
-Oh, from, like, family and --
-Oh, just every -- I mean,
this is everybody's dream
is to somehow have an in.
Because, I mean,
I know it because I've --
You've watched "Saturday Night
Live" your whole life,
and you're like, "I've got
a pretty good sketch idea."
And so then once
you get a friend
that's like, "You know,
I'm going to be there,"
they're like,
"Well, let me let it fly."
And it's just been text
and e-mail of just like,
"Run this by everybody."
Like, it just --
Nobody's a professional writer.
-Anything helpful or just does
it all feel like spam mail?
-It's all --
Like, I'm going through it.
I mean, some are like,
"Yeah, that's funny."
Then some are like, "Dude,
who do you think we are?
Like, you think I can just
walk in to
'Saturday Night Live,'
professional writers,
and just be like,
'Hey, my buddy Michael --
he took some improv
classes 40 years ago
and he's got some good ideas.
I'd like to --
I got him on the horn
if y'all want to talk to him.'"
-Well, I hope that they do talk
to Michael just for that, yeah.
-I, do too. Yeah.
-Hey, I'm so excited.
I think everybody's
going to be so excited.
Thanks so much for making time
for us on the busy week.
-You're the best, man.
-You guys, Nate Bargatze,
"SNL" Saturday, October 28th,
with the Foo Fighters,
on NBC and live on Peacock.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with Andrew Rannells.